hey guys Anna welcome back to the Leia
heilpan show joining me on the show
today we have serial entrepreneur he's a
Trader and he's managed to generate over
45 million dollars in nfts also somehow
he has managed to hack the Discord game
bringing in six multi-figure months and
get this he's only 21. Gavin Mayo
welcome to the show how are you today
I'm amazing beautiful day here in Miami
just missed the hurricane yesterday flew
in it's a little bumpy but now it's
beautiful and sunny back to normal and
glad to be here so happy to have yeah
there's just so much that I can learn
from you and a lot of people can learn
live view um I know you've been trading
since you're actually 13. is that right
so before we get into all of that um
since you are a Trader you've been
trading since you were 13 um I do
actually want to get your take on the
markets right now we've seen FDX blow up
we've seen what happened with um with
Celsius
um three hours Capital the whole market
right now looks like it is crashing so I
know you've made over eight figures
trading so give me your take what is
going on right now yeah so FTX recently
just happened that was like two days ago
so right now we're dealing with the
inverse effects of all the printing
we've done in the economy the past back
in 2020 it all started with the you know
cough cough and the little flu disease
and
we were printing so much money there was
so much money out in the open that's why
we saw people paying millions of dollars
for pixelated Apes we saw everything
going to the moon and then speculative
assets like crypto Moon even more so
first it was tech stocks a lot of these
hedge funds realized that okay now that
that flu happened they're gonna have to
start printing the economy or all the
401ks police pensions all that stuff's
going to go under so they had to prop
the markets back up and I identified
this and I made a lot of money from all
that printing in the stock markets
that's where it started and then people
were like well with all this inflation
what's going to happen Okay speculative
acid like crypto is a hedge against
inflation that's what people say and
then all the hedge funds all the people
everyone fomo'd in even the hedge funds
so we should have hit a top around 25
30k Bitcoin but we saw a way further
than that all the way up to 69k and
right around 50 60k Bitcoin I started to
realize like this what goes up must come
down and when everyone was saying to the
Moon about a year ago to the Moon we're
gonna see 100K before we see that crash
identified that and I was out of the
market I think around January I started
to get out and then fully by May after
the fomc meeting I knew it was going to
go down and I was out and then we saw a
75 drop in a week and a half and now
we're here we've been kind of stagnant
past couple months and now where there's
a lot in store
so how did you uh how did you identify
the top of the market because that's
something everybody tries to do I
personally did not identify at the top
of the market I was I was also thinking
100K was coming so how on Earth did you
know to pull your money out obviously no
one can identify the top no one can
identify the bottom I have points that I
100 think things will hit but I don't
know when so it's time and like I
couldn't have foreseen FTX happening the
other day I was I was actually long all
the way into midterms and then I
literally said after midterms I might
see a bit of a draw but the second
midterms were done
a little bit suspicious that the FTX
Fiasco happened so obviously I can't
time the top I can't time the bottom but
I know points where it's just normal
bear Mark bear markets usually last
about a year and then we have six months
of chop bull markets are usually four
years it's happened before we've seen
that 87 draw down the past two uh Cycles
from the from the top all right on the
bottom it went down 87 percent and we're
not quite there yet we have 87 from 69
000 I think is 11.5 Bitcoin now 87 you
think the pullback will be no that was
the past two I think it's gonna be worse
this time I see us hitting around 100
200 eth I was a bit more bullish back in
May but now that they've just been
playing chicken and then probably have
the markets Morgan Stanley has
manipulating the vix they've
manipulating every asset class it's been
pretty crazy what the feds are doing
they're just absolutely [__] they
print money one week they QT the next
week and Supply quoted out of the market
so I see 100 200 each five six K Bitcoin
and I know that stings but in the future
I do see eat above 10K Bitcoin above
100K I see it going way higher but we do
have to live to the inverse effects of
what's been happening with the economy
and there's no reason we shouldn't hit
those points what 2020 East was at what
like 150 what stops are going down there
in 2022 2023 what stops us from going
down 95 this time so 87 puts the 11.5
Bitcoin let's say this time around we're
dealing with inflation this time around
we're dealing with leverage a lot of
people are like well the institutions
are in all these more people have
adopted crypto I think that makes it
worse because every single bottom we
have people just re-leverage up in
crypto you could have 100K and then you
have five mil you're trading with so
that's why we're gonna we need a Black
Swan event like usdt collapsing or I
know FTX it's not quite the Black Swan
event but we had it in 2008 with the
Lehman Brothers we had it in the 2000s
with that other bank but we need that
Black Swan event to find that bottom so
the feds can capitulate and that would
be the best thing for crypto
right now we're kind of just propping it
up we're nowhere near 87 Mark I think we
have a lot of hurt to go and I say this
a lot of people call me crazy but I
guess we'll see and again I don't know
exactly when the bottom is going to be
and I'm not going to buy everything at
the bottom I'm going to set buy orders
you should always average down so let's
say at 675 you buy you know 2 million
500 each by four million 400 6 million
300 each maybe about 8 million and then
right around when the feds capitulate we
start qeating again which is printing
money again if they actually have a good
policy this time and they don't [__] it
up then that's when I'll be getting in
it's going to be public knowledge that
you know inflation has peaked they'll
probably want to see two latest readings
that'll come out we're we're resuming
limited QE and that's when you probably
want to buy or play the dead cap bounce
head down a bit a little bit of chop but
then slowly we'll grind back up and
we'll see that bull market full on ready
to go but I think we got a while to that
maybe another year okay yeah so I was
gonna ask you can you give me some kind
of timeline like when do you think we're
gonna bottom what's 20 23 gonna look
like my mind is always changing if you
guys follow my Instagram I talk about
the market all the way always on there
and one week I'll be saying something in
the next week I'll say I changed my mind
on this because events happen so back in
May whenever the feds said the amount
they were going to QT which is they're
sucking liquidity out of the market
they're selling mortgage back assets
they basically said they were going to
trim a trillion dollars off their
balance sheet and I was like okay how
can a market go up when they're just
unloading clips of just selling stuff
and the market goes up when they're
buying stuff but when they're selling
it's even worse and the FEDS tend to
overdo things so when my mind changes a
lot the timeline was in September I
thought because they were tripling up qt
in September I thought that was going to
be the nuke month I thought that's when
we were good but then we got to there
midterms are coming you know they
started propping up the markets they
wanted things to last and I still am a
little bullish right now as until
December Opex I probably think the
markets can stay up I don't think we'll
hit under a thousand each until then but
eventually I think beginning of 2023
maybe end around Christmas time that's
where we're gonna see a negative 50
month absolute catastrophe because they
just it's just been propping up that
string has to snap eventually everything
has to I think everything's gonna crash
it's going to be crypto stocks real
estate it just it has to happen and that
would be the best thing for us I don't
want to stay sideways and nothing really
happened for two three years I want to
stop
everyone get wrecked everyone never want
to touch crypto again never want to
touch any assets again and that's when
I'll be buying but I've been on the
market forever my time frame yeah I
would say beginning of 2023 we'll
probably see that nuke we'll probably
slowly head down from there and then
around the summer of next year that's
when we could have found a bottom but
again things could change we could find
that bottom in January we could find
that bottom in February or it could be
in August of next year
the sooner the better honestly I hope I
hope yeah I've been waiting I haven't
bought anything yet I just trade now so
I I'll trade anything I'll trade crypto
I'll trade stocks I'll trade nfts ens
domain names Commodities random coins
you find all over the place I trade
whatever I can find and that's that's
why I think I become a good Trader is
because let's just say you just trade
stocks there's only one or two good
setups a month or every couple months in
stocks I only take the best possible
setups I've changed my trading style
from Trading once a day to now once or
twice a month but only high probability
setups big money all these people on
there with one percent of their
portfolio and afraid to put I I'm
confident my place I haven't lost a
trade since March so I've changed my
style up so that's why I trade
everything because maybe there's one in
Forex this month and maybe there's also
one in crypto and the next month there
might be something in Commodities there
might be something with ens so that's
all you need to to make good trades
that's why I think my trading style is
the best possible style you can have
that's what makes a good Trader not
someone that just trades stocks SO
trading obviously isn't the only thing
that you do you have this incredible
Discord where you're making
um over six figures a month so I'm
confused by this like I don't understand
the Discord game you have to explain
this to me
um and like what are you selling and how
can you run a business on Discord just
explain how the whole thing works yeah
exactly it all it all started when I
decided to start making crypto and stock
videos on Tick Tock that led me to
working with this other I didn't even
know existed some some guy hit me up was
like hey we have this Discord we teach
people at stocks and I was like oh
that's cool and then I was like wait I
could just do it myself these guys don't
know what they're talking about so I did
it myself with my business partner and
we decided to put a bunch of free
education out a bunch of free when when
I make a trade I was just putting it out
that's when I was trading once a day so
it is a bit addicting to some people
some people want to go on and be like
okay Gavin's trading this today I'm
gonna I'm gonna hop in with him and this
is when the market was popping so every
day I was trading they were all hit and
everyone thought you know I was a genius
or whatever which I was a good Trader
but everyone was just lucky everyone was
sitting but yeah so we basically just
post in our community we have a bunch of
other other millionaire traders that
post their trades you can go and look at
them copy them they post trade Recaps we
have voice calls you can go in there and
listen to what other people are talking
about the markets and then you go in the
chat and talk with whoever about it so I
know that you also trade a lot of [__]
coins
um so how much money have you actually
made on [__] coins and which coins are
they I mean there's days that I would
I'd throw a hundred dollars in their
[__] coin and at the top I'd have a
million dollars and then I wouldn't sell
and I'm not even kidding a hundred
dollars a million dollars that was
completely possible with [__] coins it
all started uh with the safe Moon that
was the first [__] coin and that went to
13 billion market cap you know we were
actually talking with the founder and
whatnot when it first started it was on
a million Market I got in I got out at
like 10 ended up going a bunch more I
got back in whatever that was my first
show calling where I was like wait what
is going on what is this I was getting
got my sister my mom my friends always
hitting them up yo buy this coin and
they were like I just made 50 Grand what
the what is this so yeah [__] coins was
a crazy phase and that's what led me
into seeing that Trend and being like
okay what's the next Trend but [__]
coins were amazing I do trade them
nowadays but [__] coins are kind of dead
but that's why I say but I literally
would trade I think I'll trade tits coin
whatever they call there's so many
random coins coming out and now I do it
like you're basically throwing darts at
the wall now and one of them will hit
the rest will die so let's say I have 10
Heath I'll toss an Ethan to each one
it's kind of a systematic thing I do I
have a bot that buys I like to buy coins
at zero percent tax this is for nowadays
back in the day you could throw it Dart
the wall and everything hits but now a
buy coins a zero percent tax good
liquidity and nine out of 10 of them
will go to zero I'll lose the one eighth
but the tenth one that hits I make like
20 or 30th or whatever so just throwing
darts at the wall and that strategy
works when the market is hot and [__]
coins are kind of trending right now the
Market's down so I'm not doing it this
week but when I'm bored I'll hop on my
laptop you can you can launch coin right
now if you guys want to at home you can
go on Dex tools and put a contract in a
remix you can launch your own coin Gavin
coin layout coin whatever you want and
it's it's up to the market if people
want to buy it so yeah you just go on
Dex tools you see coins that are
launching on all the chains you can
launch a coin on Doge can ethereum chain
and yeah you just go and buy them but
yeah I just look there's so many random
coins down it's a systematic thing so
that all sounds amazing um you know
turning 100 into
um what did you say 10 100 into uh I
miss it I I miss it but then I lost it
all went down but I missed the days that
you could throw a dart at the wall turn
100 into a million but I don't think
that will ever come again well talk me
through the process though because
everybody wants to know how do I pick a
[__] coin like how do I know you know
what's gonna pump and dumps how do you
pick the coin like I wouldn't have known
Doge I wouldn't have known Shiba Inu I
didn't get any of those so how do you
know which [__] coins to pick and then
also how do you know when to get in and
when to sell that's the million dollar
question if you knew what these coins
were gonna go but back in the day it was
it's it's a completely unregulated space
where these random people some of the
people that launched the best coins
they just kept they were all the same
ones like this you know the safe Moon
guys were all the same ones so you have
to look at the team
another thing I look at is whale wallets
and some people track my wallet
sometimes but you can look at people
with hundreds of million dollars there's
some whales that go in and buy you know
Shiba Inu or whatever these coins are
when you see that you know some big boys
are involved they're all in a little
group chat hey watch this and sometimes
me and my boys used to go in and just
buy random [__] coins and just and then
people would see our wallets by and they
just jump in and then we just you know
we G so it's kind of a strategy in and
out but there's no way to identify coins
nowadays it's usually just random
sometimes a founder of an old really big
coin you'll find out that they and I got
no coin like two weeks ago that it was
some founder of this old Bitcoin and
everyone was like all right time to go
and then liquidity you also look at so
how much liquidity is the coin starting
with it's like 510k liquidity it's
probably just some 15 year old kid in
their bedroom so you got to look at a
few different things but nowadays you
need zero tax if it's taxed it's
probably an actual [__] coin but for the
most part I wouldn't touch them they're
kind of dead they'll probably come back
someday but it is the best way if you're
some kid in high school you can make
millions of dollars with it but it's
kind of died down now
so I want to talk about nfts
um because that blew up during the bull
market you know it was my bread and
butter you actually generated 45 million
dollars yes me and my team yeah what
does that mean how did you generate so
much money in nfts so for you you guys
that don't know nfts non-fungible token
a fungible token would be something like
the dollar you can you know make a bunch
of them and twenty dollars versus a
hundred dollars a non-fungible token
it's on the blockchain there's only one
of one so when that nerd is at the party
telling the girl hey this Apes mine it's
actually mine no one can have it it's
one of one it's completely yours it's on
the blockchain that's how you verify it
so because we were in [__] coins we
identified the nft trend very very
quickly around July there was there was
the two projects punks and apes you guys
always see the Apes I mean it's on a
building in Miami right now I was
looking at the other day it's crazy all
nfts have integrated into society but
we identified around July that these
projects started to launch I think it
was one or two it's like pudgy penguins
and a few of these other projects and I
remember seeing them and my business
partner talked to his friend and he was
like I just launched an fft project and
he was like I made two million dollars
and we were like what you're selling
pictures of apes for two million dollars
so I was actually in Africa at the time
and I came home straight away at home we
all sat down we talked it was end of
July beginning August and literally all
you had to do to launch an nft project
was to find some kid from Russia and say
hey Mass DM This Server and I don't know
if you guys know how Discord works but
there's a bunch of users on Discord and
there is a bot that can just go through
and send them a link so we would just
send them a link to our Discord to all
these random people and other nft
discords that already sold out it's all
these kids that bought pudgy Penguins
boom just send them a link to this
Discord like what's this project oh wow
the Art's really cool all right I'm
gonna buy one and that was how you could
sell out a project all the way to
October and then when we get it we
started getting very very good nfts and
we made a name for herself in the space
is we started to Pioneer a lot of
strategies so we came up with a bunch of
different marketing strategies because
it started to get harder more and more
people caught on that I could be a 15
year old in my bedroom and make two
million dollars and sell digital art so
you could sell a project in a week but
then it started to get more than that
you have to have utility the founders
have to be dogs you have to have some
hype or some famous person has to tweet
about so there was the celebrity phase
every celebrity when they tweet about it
oh it's going to the Moon then that died
down then the Twitter phase came then
just you had to be very creative so we
always very we're very very creative in
to manufacture hype because that's all
it is the only thing stopping you from
making millions of dollars is making its
Supply to men who who wants your project
well I don't know if there's no one in
the Discord and no one cares about it no
one's gonna buy it and if an nft project
doesn't sell out boom to zero and that's
why you see a lot of these nft kids
always complain you know crying about
how they lost money I mean first off
you're signing up to buy a digital
picture of there was the stupidest
projects there's one project that was
literally blank sheets and when went up
to like couple youth or whatever so if
it doesn't sell out the Project's done
so it's out of the founders control you
can't complain about it you sign up to
buy an nft and if the project sells out
as a good chance of going up but for the
most part every nft that launched even
if it was by really really good team the
all the prices are at zero there's a few
of our projects that are above mint
price but for the most part there's
nothing we can really do and a lot of
the times I'll be the one marketing
pioneering it telling them what to do
projects would come to me beg I didn't
work with a lot it would only be with
business partners but they would come to
us say Hey how do we Market this we'd
show them we didn't really own anything
outright but we own percents and yeah we
were I would say the Dustin nft game I
don't think anybody compared yeah I mean
for over 45 million dollars is is pretty
wild so you've done it and that's not
that's not Drop Shipping profits that
people are like oh we had 45 million
dollars but only 2 million profit that's
45 million dollars in a bunch of wallets
boom dunzo that's liquid so it's almost
like a you know if we were to value a
business then if we had a business at
the time but yeah we would just come on
as independent contractors and generate
the money you know no it was absolutely
crazy so you've done nfts you've done
the [__] coin game
um and the next one which I've heard you
talk about is um ens I know you think
ens is going to be the next big thing so
what is ens and also how are you
positioning yourself so that you can
monetize and and you know take a piece
of that market like I said we had chick
coins first phase nft second phase where
you could turn millions of dollars on
anything I think the third thing just
before we hear what Gavin thinks the
next big trend is going to be in crypto
I want to tell you about corium and
something I think could be quite popular
in the next Bull Run which are smart
tokens currently smart contracts that
execute terms of an agreement without a
middleman can be quite expensive not
very secure and also quite inefficient
which means it's not optimal for
issuance and tokenization that's where
smart tokens come in and corium is the
very first blockchain to issue these
they are natively issued tokens wrapped
around smart contracts that function
independently they're customizable
lightweight and flexible smart tokens
can be programmed for stable coins
peer-to-peer secure messaging real
estate tokenization and transparent
voting so clearly some very compelling
use cases and I'll be keeping a close
eye on corium and smart tokens in the
next Bull Run now let's hear what Gavin
thinks we'll take off in the next bull
market the next Trend everyone's always
like what's the next Trend metaverse
this and that I think it's ens there's
only one of one you can create a million
nft projects a million [__] coins ens is
one of one so for you guys that don't
know what ens is ethereum name service
you can check it up do your research but
for all you crypto people at home if I
want to send you 10 billion dollars
around I could in one second just send
ethereum for ens it's just leia.eth
let's say you register leia.i boom just
send it there Gavin Dottie you just sent
it to Gavin Dolly so it's a way to have
that Flex of a name almost like
Instagram usernames you know my
Instagram is at Mayo you know it's a
nice clean name I have friends that have
really really cool Instagram names so
it's kind of like that but it's on the
blockchain and it's just like the.com
names so back in the 1990s when everyone
was making fun of everyone wait what is
this internet thing why are you
registering these.com names well they're
not laughing the past couple years where
amazon.com could sell for a billion
dollars today it's the same thing with
the blockchain what's the future what's
everyone laughing about now crypto's not
the future everybody says that what's
everyone laughing about now in a couple
years crypto is probably going to be the
future it's going to be integrated in
society everyone that doesn't have it
now is going to be integrated with it so
what's going to be a clear-cut winner
either Bitcoin or ethereum or both and
if ethereum is the clear-cut winner then
all these names like Gavin Dottie
amazon.ieth and it already started
amazon.eth gotta offer for a million
dollars
porno.eath got an offer for 100 I think
Patriots just bought their ens domain
and patriots.he sold for 75 eth so a lot
of these names are already starting but
I identified this trend very early on
and I could go through and I could have
spent a bunch of money 20 30 each on all
these premium names which I will be
doing eventually but I'm gonna wait for
the market to get nuked first so what I
did and I was surprised to find I was
sitting in the sauna one day and I had
this idea I was surprised to find that
names in other languages were not taken
so what did I do I went I went and found
that the top 500 names in English were
all available in other languages so I
sat for about a week in my room
registered every single Arabic name
Hebrew name Chinese name I got
everything I got you know Muhammad Ali I
got punk in other language Bitcoin
Dottie ferrari.eth rolex.heath all these
brand names and other languages and
let's just say Dubai adopts crypto what
are they going to want they're not going
to want English ens names they're going
to want hey send it to my wallet
muhammad.if and I monopolize the market
so now I can set the floor price and not
sell any of them so what are they going
to pay it's just like a flex it's just
like those number plates in Dubai they
want to flex they're going to want to
flex on their friends yeah did you see
that I have bitcoin.eath but it's in
Arabic they speak Arabic there so why
would they not want that so I have a
monopoly over the market I plan to hold
them until 8th is at that huge balloon
and let's just say some of the English
names are going for a couple hundred
each I can set my Arabic and other
languages at 100 eth and guess what I
only registered fifty dollars I put the
guada 18 it registered overnight three
year registration 50 bucks I spent 10 20
each I identify that opportunity if one
name pops off it's going to sell for way
over 20. so I basically made my money
back times one thousand and I think
that's my plan I will become a
billionaire from it as long as ens is
the clear-cut winner and ethereum is the
clear-cut winner but you also have other
ones like it takes a few years for them
to be traded in the secondary market so
you got the dot world names which I'm in
all these names so I I have like a
thousand dot world names there's only
eight thousand registered Adult World W
and S they don't have a renewal renewal
fees which is nice but it's just another
it's just like a dot-con you know
there's.com dot e they have a BNB one
they it's just on the Block on that
blockchain so the dot world names I
think could be a clear-cut winner
there's only 8 000 registrations right
now ens has millions takes a few years
so if ens doesn't win and another one is
a clear-cut winner I still own a lot of
those too so I've taken a very big stake
in all these names if it is in the
future I didn't risk much if it is the
future I should become a billionaire
liquid that's the plan that's insane so
how many uh how many domains do you own
thousands that I mean I like I said I S
I spent 20 30 I I have good English
names too like you know I have like
Lakers Dottie uh you can also register
emojis you can register like three
smiley face it has to be three
characters at least so you can like do
like three smiley face that go there's
different clubs you can check on
different websites and see the clubs
like there's a three-digit Club so zero
zero zero zero youth is technically the
most valuable name or like I have 074
and like those do really well there was
palindrons I spent a week of registering
as many palindrance as I could find so
that's like rotor spelled backwards is
rotor Hannah spelled backwards is Hannah
so there's different ones that are a
little bit more valuable or I'll I'll
like do let's say Dubai flag UAE
something like that and I put a bunch of
flags with the cities uh American flag
SF American flag La stuff like that I I
try to register about 100 names a day
when I'm not busy when I'm just chilling
on my computer I've thought about
getting a VA but they could never figure
it out and I just sit there and yeah
you know who you sound like you sound
like Michael say live because that's
what Michael Saylor did he uh he bought
all these.com names um you know he's got
Michael dot um.com so that's incredible
and he you know he clearly um made a lot
of money from that so if you are if
you're right then you could be on the
same track as Michael Saylor that's the
plan and that that's what I'm good at is
identifying those Trends thinking of
things that other people don't think of
and that's especially how I trade I
don't go with the crowd I literally do
the opposite so that's that is the plan
we'll see what happens even if it
doesn't know really risk on my part so
it was a beautiful play one of the best
plays I've had you know always
fascinates me
um I always want to know how much
intelligence versus luck comes into this
so you know can anybody be an
entrepreneur can anybody make money
um you know how much intelligence is
needed to do all the things that you've
done I talk about this sometimes with my
friends and we're wondering you know
because there's there's friends that we
have and we've tried to help them make
money or whatever and they just can't
and I don't know if it's genetic making
money or it's a mindset which I think it
is mindset because I think anybody can
develop if you spend every day waking
second with some billionaire and you're
just some kid you should
know enough to make a million dollars
now there's also a difference between
you can be a smart person and have a
high IQ but not be smart if that makes
sense so I think of it like a CPU your
computer your IQ is your RAM that you
can process at what speed whatever if
it's clogged up with a bunch of junk and
you're eating junk food all day and
you're watching porn and all this stuff
that's just messing with your brain you
could have a very high IQ but not be
able to operate and it's completely out
of your control like productivity is
completely out of control if you're
doing all this stuff and it brings me to
a study there's actually a study because
mice's brains are kind of the same as
humans there's this study that they put
this little dope the the mice would
press the dopamine thing and it would
give them little hits of dopamine all
the mice would do all day press dopamine
they'd have a female mice in there they
weren't interested I don't want the
female mice just press the dopamine they
even put them on the other side and put
a bunch of shock wires so they have the
pass to get to the dopamine and they
still pressed it so what does that tell
us humans no matter what even if they
know it's bad for us even if we know
eating hot Cheetos and watching porn all
day is bad for us and isn't going to be
good for our future we don't care all we
our our brain only wants the least least
resistance just dopamine give me
dopamine video games porn Cheetos that
gives me dopamine quick I don't have to
work for it so even if you know it's not
good for you so that's what I say a lot
productivity sometimes out of your
control you need to push that stuff away
here's an easy way to become productive
super easy so what you do you take
everything out of your life to give you
a little quick dopamine hits you stop
eating junk food all I eat is raw
chicken raw steak nothing that is
palatable I just you know shots of olive
oil take it down so I have no dopamine
being released from that I have no video
games I have no social media that is I'm
not I don't scroll through it I use it
for business so what else do you have to
do well uh there's nothing to do oh
there's a computer right there oh I'm
bored I can stare at the wall I can
start my business so if you have nothing
else that is bogging your brain down
you're going to start your business
because then oh wait I'm making a little
bit of money oh that gives me a little
dopamine hit because I'm not getting it
from other things so that's what you
need to find fulfillment in life is
getting those little dopamine hits from
starting your business and then voila
every time you make money you get that
don't be hit and you're addicted to it
I'd rather be addicted to making money
and starting businesses than hot Cheetos
and porn
I agree with you I think making money is
much better than Cheetos and porn so so
why do you think people are so stuck on
those bad habits and you know are unable
to sort of follow the path that you
thought they don't know any better
they ever everything in life is pretty
much designed to make people zombies all
the food we consume all everything we
drink ever everything is designed to
keep people stupid and if you don't have
that education and I I'm very observant
so if something isn't working or I had
brain fog back in the day I was like
there had this isn't how humans are
meant to be I knew there was another way
and there was dopamine detox I checked
up but all these YouTubers just say the
same thing just all you have to do is
just use some common sense you know it's
bad for you just think I think very
critically about things so there's it's
kind of out of people's control
hopefully they watch this and they think
about it and just try it for a week why
not just try it for a week take
everything away that gives you the
doping dopamine hits and you're going to
be so bored and you'll be like oh damn
I've been meeting to start that business
[__] it I'll just whatever
so let's get into a bit more detail on
that what how is life designed to keep
you like a zombie like would you have an
example I mean I guess I can go a little
more deeper into it the world is run by
some people what is everything you see
everything you consume everything we
wear everything we eat is controlled by
you know a few top people and the way it
works is let's just say you pick a
random company Coca-Cola okay who's the
top institutional hoarders of Coca-Cola
you can go through everyone pull out
your phone right now on Yahoo finance go
in the Insiders who who owns it I don't
know a bunch of hedge funds oh wait at
the top I see Vanguard Morgan Stanley
BlackRock okay what about a competitor
that you go into Pepsi they own
who's the top holders Vanguard BlackRock
the same people but how are they
competitors the same people own it
that's what they do okay I flew here on
an airplane who owns Boeing Vanguard
BlackRock random these random trust
companies they all the top holders of
Vanguard BlackRock okay who owns Morgan
Stanley wait BlackRock does so it's a
pyramid structure the smaller hedge
funds are owned by the other
institutions than other institutions all
the way at the top is Blackrock but wait
who owns BlackRock Vanguard because you
can see who owns BlackRock who owns
BlackRock Vanguard the top holders of
Vanguard or who oh you can't find it
they have a unique structure where you
can't find the people that own Vanguard
so everything we consume the media what
we eat everything is owned by the same
companies and it's complete Monopoly
that's what it is so it's all designed
for your guess is as good as mine I'm
sure we can think of it I'm sure people
can think of it at home why this happens
but
that's my guess so if you can't if the
structure of Vanguard is vague and you
can't see who already owns it who do you
think owns it
I mean I remember researching I found
this out as a young kid just researching
stocks because I used to go on Yahoo
finance I was a very analytical investor
and I started to see this and I was like
this makes no sense how does this happen
but obviously the
very very wealthy families maybe royalty
who knows your guess is as good as mine
and they own the money they own this
everything even even the FED I don't
know if people don't know this the Fed
was kind of unconsciously
unconstitutionally created so there was
these three guys you know they wanted to
start a federal reserve and then these
three guys were kind of opposing it
they're very very wealthy men at the
time I think they had like 500 million
in today's currency it's like 13 or 14
billion who knows what it's going to be
with inflation in a few years but these
guys ended up all dying on the Titanic
suspicious so there was no one to really
oppose them and then well uh I think
around 1913 it passed and the Fed was
created and then in 2008 they created
the beautiful Ponzi of QE where they
print a bunch of money there's a bunch
of money in the economy but if you
understand it like me you can identify
those opportunities and there's a bunch
of money floating around all right let
me get in fed's printing I'm getting
those tech stocks I'm getting those
speculative assets and then the feds
doing the complete opposite of that
which is QT and a lot of people don't
understand this and I never see anybody
buddy talk about it because no one does
the research that no one looks at
everyone's on Twitter just talking about
printing this and that but they don't
actually understand it I check the
things that no one checks QT that's
quantitative tightening they're sucking
liquidity out of the market they're
selling mortgage back assets especially
bonds no one buys bonds that's a lot of
downward pressure and the FEDS tend to
overdo it like I said earlier so when
they were printing Burr money printer go
up it's gonna be the same thing when
they're sucking liquidity out they're
going to overdo it it's like buying a
[__] coin for one eat every time you buy
for one eat someone sells two each
that's the FED they're the ones selling
so that's coming and they have to do it
they can't lower the key interest rate
they are going to have to force a
recession and what I'm nervous about is
they might force a depression and then
who knows crypto could go away
completely that's what people don't
understand it's possible it's all
consumer confidence I don't think it
will but if depression comes you guys
better get better get ready or what is
it beginning in November we'll see maybe
when this thing airs it could be it
could get pretty bad I see again nuke 50
one month even lower the next month it's
gonna be nuts so how can people prepare
themselves
right now if you're still in the market
again you can always do we want and I
could be completely wrong who knows you
don't just listen to some random guy on
the internet you know I know what I'm
talking about and you can check all my
plays on Instagram and whatnot but again
I would be in cash I would be ready I
wouldn't be in real estate I wouldn't be
in you know watches like these are these
are great and all and I mean even this
has gone down I see some watches going
under retail
I would just be in cash I would be
prepared try to trade make modest gains
every day if you're not a Trader there's
just travel the world just chill there's
no point of trying to to get in this and
then that try to produce cash or get it
ready have it on the sidelines and then
set and buy orders average down so when
you think let's say people think it's
gonna be 700 bottom for each you can
start buying at 700 but just average
down maybe I'm right and then you'll be
happy that you didn't put all the money
in at 700 like average down you know two
four six eight ten that's my plan you
know 2 million at this 4 million at this
6 million at this identify those key
points you can use ta that's great and
all but for the most part just you can
buy weekly and then whenever
they start printing again that's when
they're going to see they're going to
announce it publicly at the FED meeting
and that will be a good indication that
bull market back on let's go Trends it's
going to start heading up and uh most of
the coins will be at zero by then but I
think Ethan Bitcoin will make it till
then yeah I agree with you I don't think
many coins are going to survive ethereum
Bitcoin 100 just like the Internet it's
going to be like the internet stocks
back in 1990s pretty much everything
went to zero but no one thought Amazon
and Google that those were gonna go up
they you know so I think Amazon's like
four dollars at one point so there could
be a crypto that we don't even know
about that's the future who knows but
for now
only time can tell so I'm interested how
has money changed your life what kind of
Lifestyle are you living now how is it
different to um your life before this
I love much more modest life now much
more classy but I did go through the
hedonistic stuff and of course money
changes your life a lot of people say
money doesn't matter first off it's a
coping mechanism it a hundred percent
[__] matters it's very important but
again money isn't a measure of success I
see this a lot with people you have to
understand that so it's definitely
changed my life I'm able to do any if I
want to go tomorrow to Peru marry a nice
Peruvian wife go grow crops in the
mountains and just sit there forever
that's what I do if I want to run for
president someday I need money to do
that if I don't go to prove I need money
to do that if you want to follow your
dreams you need money so it's definitely
important I know I can take care of my
family now I don't have to think about
when I go out to dinner I don't have to
think about I just want to you know how
you you're able to hop on a jet whenever
time travel you know I could I could be
in Miami in two three hours just go
faster it's it's a beautiful thing it's
very important to have there are a few
things above it but again money helps
facilitate those things above it anyway
so it is literally the same money makes
the world go around
so you're only 21
um and I know that money is good for
women so I'm interested to know how your
dating life has changed since you made
money are you able to kind of get any
kind of woman you want like money money
definitely helps the game but at the end
of the day I swear these girls don't
know the difference between you having
100K or bank account and 100 Mil unless
they come from a wealthy family and
realistically I like to date girls that
have money because they're not really
impressed by money like you know pick
them up in the lambo oh this is nice
cool they're picking me up in like a
Rolls-Royce I like to date girls like
that they just they already have money
but some of the girls that don't I I
have a Urus they don't even know they
don't even know it's a Lamborghini until
they get in the car some some girls
don't even know about cars you know you
just pull up like a cars never help me
pick up a girl so money helps facilitate
things obviously they want a nice car to
pick them up take them out to dinner and
take them back to a nice apartment or
nice house as long as you're not living
on Skid Row in La I think you'll be fine
so it definitely helps you're able to be
spontaneous with it you know you can go
out you can do whatever I could fly
across the country to see a girl
whatever so it definitely helps but it's
not everything and a lot of people in a
lot especially a lot of these crypto
kids don't realize that money
is not going to get you girls but it
will help you live the life that girls
like so you could have a hundred
thousand dollars in your pocket girls
don't care it actually is a bit of a
turn off for them so it's definitely
helped me but not in that way
and a lot of people think that they can
just sit back and not worry about girls
oh just money if I save three minutes a
day I can I don't have to talk to this
girl and I can work in my business it is
important because if you're 24 years old
you finally made your first million and
you've never been in a relationship with
a girl you're gonna get wrecked you're
gonna get absolutely obliterated you you
get into that relationship she's
probably gonna play you or you're you're
not going to know how to treat her you
have to go through all those heartbreaks
you know you know have that back in high
school and you need to have that now
fast and it also translates to business
just being good with women translates
the business so that is an area of
expertise that you should be proficient
in if you're a man and other things like
Health woman and money those are the
three things I would say those are
important
so of course you need money to get in
the door right like women want to know
that you can pick them up take them
places or whatever you need money to get
in the door
um but you're sort of touching on
something else you're saying you need
something else to keep them yeah you
need substance you so if you ended if
you were to take a broke man someone
that has no money their name and they
have game and they know how to just talk
and be a genuine person and a good
person versus one of these idiot crypto
kids
the girl's gonna pick the broke eye any
day of the week it doesn't matter it's
all about game so and not like you know
these games playing this and that just
being able to talk being playful with
them like just being a genuine person
knowing how to treat staff and just
being a real man that's what I would say
so you have to have substance to you you
can have money and be a complete idiot
so
it's funny because you mentioned about
being a real man in your view what is
being a real man even mean
so there to be a real man a lot of
people use the phrase high value man you
need a lot of things it is a process and
I'm in that Pioneer phase right now you
can always improve as a person so
obviously you have to have your finances
order you have to be woke about the
world you have to know what's going on
you can't just you know walking around
not knowing what's going on I think you
should be able to fight you should have
health you should have all that stuff in
order you should be intelligent know how
to treat people know how to talk to
people there's you know people always
talking under their breath not just see
it in in people are just rude to staff
all the time I always notice that maybe
it's an LA thing but there's a lot of
things to be a real man you need to
constantly be working on yourself and
that's the beautiful thing about being
man it's like a game you can build
yourself from scratch it's like
literally a video game so it's a
beautiful thing and I think that's what
men love is that conquering and getting
better and that's the beautiful thing
about the world being a man but it's
interesting because I feel like nobody
wants to be a man like me personally a
man is about taking personal
responsibility protecting providing
being powerful
um you know leading nobody wants to do
that anymore I mean you're quite unique
you know I know I've known a Few Good
Men
um but it's not that common anymore
that's why they kind of call it the one
percent man it's it's very hard to find
if you went up to 100 people in Miami on
the street right now it'd probably be
hard to even find the man we're
describing and that's fine there's
there's not many of us out there but
people just don't care people maybe
think that they're not consuming this
type of content so what they see in the
movies and on the show oh I'm a high
value man I open the door for the girls
or whatever I mean they just don't see
the stuff that we're talking about so
that's what I'd say it's definitely
tough to find a high value man I I agree
but they're they're out there that's why
I've built a network for myself I I
don't really I won't pick up the phone
if it's just some idiot or whatever I've
built a network of hopefully high value
men and in all Realms so money is one
thing but if you're a money and you if
you have a bunch of money and you know
how to act I don't care I don't want to
be around you I don't want you to be in
my network so it's just everything you
know I have a network it's a group chat
and we just talk about money we talk
about whatever in there anything you
need yo I need I need to be in this
flight private jet tomorrow boom done I
need shipping containers in China
anything they just put in the chat boom
done we got about 170 people now and
it's basically like a mini Network
across the world I'm in Miami right now
I met up with a bunch of the guys and
when you have access to one of your
friends networks and then they have
access to that Network and it just grows
and grows and grows but it's not like a
payment thing that I see a lot of these
groups you have to pay to be in it but
it's completely free to join but we vet
you and I have done business with you or
one of the other admins have to do
business with you and then we're
probably gonna start doing interviews
soon if it's just like a random person
but someone asked the voucher in the
group it's a beautiful thing but that's
what I think men should try to find is a
strong Network there are a bunch of good
networks out there but ideally you know
if money's the only way to get in that's
where these networks kind of fail
because you could be an idiot with money
and then get into these networks and
then it kind of poisons so I you know we
have very very strict guidelines and
it's not a it's not a money thing we
don't need the money from the people
it's all about Network
yeah network is so important um it
really is all about who you know um but
you know speaking of being an idiot with
money I know you talk a lot about these
La kids
um that just don't know what they're
doing you know what's it like in LA
there's a lot of degeneracy we've spoken
about um you know before we did the
podcast I call them I call them crypto
kids or nft kids and they basically have
no substance to them whatsoever except
for money they made a bit of money and a
lot of them are broke now a lot of them
lost all that money because we're
talking you know you sold out your nft
project for two million dollars back
last year that's probably down that
money's down like 80 now and then
doesn't mention all the money that you
probably spend on dumb [__] I know a kid
one of these crypto kids to spend 500k
at the club in one month
and obviously ended up working out
because I think he spent it at like 4K
each so it's better than it going down
to the market but you just see these
kids and they're the worst type of
people they're always lying how much
money did you make this month where I
was out at a I don't go to parties much
but I was at this Halloween party I'm
just talking with this you know it says
Drop Shipping kid and this girl comes
over and he just starts just my dad owns
Uber oh you're an actress I can do this
for you I can do that for you and they
just he he tries to bring money in the
conversation the girl's like what the
like or like I have a million like these
kids they're always like I have a
million dollars come in my car come back
to my place for the pastor party or
whatever it's it's crazy they have no
substance to them they made their money
too quickly so that's the issue so in
the history of mankind you've never been
able to buy tits coin and make a million
dollars but if you're a 15 16 year old
room in your bed never grew into your
body never learn anything about business
never to interact with humans and you
make millions of dollars that quickly
kind of [__] with you the best thing
that can happen to you is you lose all
that money and then the next time around
you know you're smart enough but these
kids they made that money now they have
no substance to them they made it easy
and now they're just running around La
being a bunch of jackasses they're just
being idiots and they're just rude to
staff not good people to be around
not my favorite crowd I wouldn't say
that I'm a crypto kid uh I'd like to be
friends with people with brick and
mortar business people that went through
that struggle obviously I started really
young if I would have just gotten to
crypto last year with all this nft stuff
I'd probably be one of those kids but
luckily I think it should be like a
chart your network should be like a
chart you make a bunch of money goes
down to zero make a bunch of money goes
down to zero and then finally it's time
okay the last two times I lost it all
and then boom and that's what happened
that's why I started trading when I was
13 years old uh my parents thought I was
so stupid but they were like oh I wanted
to prove them wrong because their
financial advisor kept saying don't
trade don't trade he's going to lose all
his money so they wanted me to to lose
my money so I took a thousand dollars my
birthday money turn it into a bunch of
money and then
I thought I was all good I just got
lucky I didn't know what I was doing but
I got lucky and then I lost almost all
of it and that taught me my first lesson
okay now I'm honing in I'm not letting
my parents be right and then I started
making it back up and then I kind of
lost a little bit and then the beautiful
Discord stuff came around and that was
my first big money and that's when I
started to really learn and like work
you know when I work hard I make money
that's how it works so and it's not like
I bought these nfts I was making them I
was staying up every night figuring out
okay how can I manufacture this hype how
can I get this guy to buy this pixel on
the screen for a couple thousand dollars
and it's crazy and it worked out
so what do you think it takes to find
fulfillment if it's not money
so obviously again money can facilitate
that but
there's a there was a study done you
guys should watch this video it was a
Harvard study longest study of human
history and they took people that one
was actually ended up being a U.S
president they took kids from inner
cities in Boston they took Harvard kids
and they would scan their brains they'd
interview them every month they'd do all
this type of stuff it was very very
articulate they'd interview the wives
and all the data came in finally the
study was finished it was Generations
like there was the the guy that started
this study his grandson finished the
study so it was a long time and what did
they find out it was on human happiness
they found out that first loneliness
kills and second
quality over quantity relationships
is what makes people happy people live
longer if they had quality relationships
whether it's men woman just being with
your friends being with your wife
whatever and that was the most important
thing and that's what drives you now
it's money you know not not gambling not
the hedonist and stuff not going to the
club none of that mattered and so there
was a bunch of people that made money
from the study they were Harvard
graduates and none of that ended up
correlating to happiness so and the
people that lived the longest had the
healthiest relationships so that after
reading that I was like okay again that
makes sense because everyone's always
like does money by happiness well yes it
can facilitate it but really what bios
happiness is having that Network having
those Human Relationships that's what we
live for and I think family super
important being able to have a bunch of
kids someday to carry on your legacy a
lot of these females or even males all I
want to work in my 20s and not have kids
and then when they're 50 years old oh
great you got to buy a bunch of makeup
and Louis Vuitton bags but wait you
don't have any kids and no one's really
in your life anymore so that's the
number one thing relationship first over
money any day you can always make more
money just floating out there I just
talked about the FED they just they're
printed all over the place they're gonna
do it again just go pick some up it's
out there yeah telling people that your
career is um you know all you need is is
such a scam and you know there's a
massive war on the family unit right now
and there's you know it's all a scam but
one scam that I hear you talk about a
lot is water so when I heard this I was
like damn I gotta ask this guy what on
Earth he's talking about why is water a
scam and does that mean you don't drink
any water what do you need water for to
stay alive isn't like 80 of our body
just that's just what people think they
also think they need sleep and all this
stuff I don't need that stuff not for me
basically I only drink fruit juice I eat
cucumber let's say I'm thirsty I go in
the fridge get some watermelon eat some
cucumbers that's hydration there's water
molecules in those Foods if you're
cooking a stick what comes off of it
steam what is that water molecule so I
just eat raw meat I eat raw chicken raw
tuna raw steak that's where I get my
hydration from I get my hydration from
those fruits from fruit juice water just
dilutes the vitamins in your body a lot
no you never hear anybody say this but
try just drinking fruit juice and
vegetables and fruits for a week and
you'll feel like Superman all these
people they need Adderall to focus they
need coffee you'll need any of that when
you don't drink water it's a scam and
then also the water that people are
drinking anyways it's like tap water
with a bunch of fluoride and bottle
plastic bottles that are set in the sun
with a bunch of who knows what in it so
that's another reason I don't drink it
it's all just [__] but you also got to
get your fruit from high quality places
too don't be going to Walmart and
getting that fruit genetically modified
but do you not like get thirsty
no I just yes whatever no it's not
whatever like if I'm thirsty I just I
just you know blink I'm like I'm not
thirsty anymore what are you doing I
just swallow I swallow what do you do at
the gym so that's one thing that I'm
pioneering right now I I was off I was a
D1 athlete and I got injured pretty bad
I broke a few bones in an accident so
right now I just work with a private
trainer trying to like I had a lot of
problems so I'm trying to fix those
problems I'm not doing too much uh I
can't really do heavy weight stuff just
yet but for the most part it's just
fixing all my all my body problems but I
take Health very seriously because it's
not for my body it's for my brain like
yeah you know I look good and stuff but
I want my brain to be perfectly
optimized but when you're at the gym are
you not thirsty so don't you go yeah I
put a little bit of fruit juice maybe
some chia seeds what do you mean fruit
juice because then fruit juices like
foot of sugar and sugars yeah if you're
getting it from Walmart but yeah freshly
pressed fruit orange juice watermelons
whatever all just freshly pressed like
there's a lot of freshly plus places in
La can my assistant go pick them up boom
got a bunch of fruit juice for the week
and I'll just mix it with whatever or
maybe I put some collagen in there and
yeah is it just is it organic fruit yeah
it's literally let's just say you took
an orange right now press the orange
what does it turn into liquid Juice
drink it or you can just eat the orange
same thing so I'm still confused like
what's bad about water because I get how
tap water is vitamins in your body you
don't need it it dilutes the vitamins in
your body yeah you don't need it how did
you how did you know that you can't
knock it until you try it no I'm just
trying to learn how do you know that
I know a lot of things but I do have I
work with a diet guy very very smart man
and that's a lot of stuff I learned from
him and I've implemented it and it's not
like I'm just like oh I feel better we
actually test it so I get my blood test
and I go back and see did my
testosterone raise by adding this thing
and did this raise so I actually tested
I come from a mathematical perspective
of it okay did this actually proven
increase it and it does so a lot of
people they just want to do these diets
and stuff but check your blood levels
see if the diet actually works so yeah I
don't drink water I don't eat cooked
Foods my diet is cooked you never cook
your food like you I don't know only raw
meat you don't ever it depends like
sometimes I'll order from like some
health places and they they cook the
chicken and when I go out to eat I'm
always like it's blue rare you have to
say blue rare because that means like
it's like rare is good but blue rare
means like barely cooked but they always
they always cook it like medium but for
the most part I'll eat cooked meat if
I'm at a restaurant it's nice but after
you eat raw meat enough your body will
first off never create junk food again
and you'll never crave cooked food again
your body's meant to eat raw meat it's
the it's the easily digestible food so
if you eat a raw egg right now it takes
30 minutes to digest if you had a cooked
egg it takes 45 minutes so I don't I
don't got time for my body to be
thinking about digesting stuff my
brain's got to think so I just eat the
steak eat the raw chicken and people
like oh salmonella wait wait wait wait
wait just pause a second raw everything
whatever no no humans are meant to eat
this stuff chicken
what's the difference between raw
chicken and raw tuna you eat sushi right
yeah I don't know but I know what's the
difference
salmonella stuff but someone else it's
just the bacteria that's found in your
gut already the reason people get sick
from salmonella is because they're
eating Cheetos in their room all day and
their body's all messed up anyway so
then have that salmonella in their body
their body doesn't know what to do with
it and it's too much and they get
diarrhea or whatever but no I've never
gotten sick from Office do you kick your
do you cook no you don't cook okay do
you um do you make your own meals no no
never that's such a low Roi activity
never but I either order uh from these
special I I order from a butcher a lot
so I'll go get bone marrow liver raw
meat I'll just put it uh sometimes leave
it out I leave my eggs out you're not
supposed to refrigerate your eggs and
then you know just toss them down and
okay about the chicken so like you like
say you have a chicken breast you just
eat it don't don't listen to me at home
if you're getting your food from Walmart
and you don't have much money because
it's expensive I go I get very very high
quality butchers I get some of my food
from Amish farms in Pennsylvania okay
and that's what you got to eat the high
quality stuff you don't be eating bone
marrow from Walmart and stuff that that
stuff is all farm raised a bunch of soy
proteins in the chicken and stuff if
you're eating chicken from Walmart yeah
I agree you're gonna get sick but if
you're getting your chicken from a nice
butcher or you just raise your own
chickens in your room or whatever and
you just eat them okay okay you go to
the best place ever highest quality food
highest quality a lot of people don't
talk about that they talk about these
all these diets and stuff but high
quality food is most important if you're
eating all this stuff from Walmart
you're gonna have issues yeah but you're
just not cooking the chicken then you're
actually eating chicken raw is that
what's happening yeah for the most part
you've never been ill from eating raw
chicken I feel amazing after faster just
depends sometimes I'll just toss it down
it's good for you also hydrates you the
water molecules you know if you cook it
you're you're cooking it it's harder to
digest again we don't got time for that
I don't all right well next time I'm in
La I'm having I'm gonna I'm gonna cook
it I'm gonna cook you but prepare you
get you some nice raw chicken cut it up
I'll show you what's up I'll put a
little bit of you know put some like
sauces and stuff maybe a little bit of
spice
the raw chicken's gonna be tough for you
to palette at first yeah and another
thing if you're eating these raw meats
but constantly it's not really palatable
so you're not gonna be as hungry so a
lot of people that eat fried foods it's
easy to eat because it tastes so good so
if you're ever trying to lose weight try
the raw diet because you'll get full
Fast one steak raw will fill you up
versus two steaks cooked I have a
question about that the how do you eat
the fat because you can't really eat it
when it's raw but when you cook it it
becomes softer so you just the Fat's the
best thing for you
just put in your mouth
I did a fascinating say all right I'm
gonna have to I'll have to try this
let's try it you got to just be like a
machine boom I'll take shots of olive
oil boom get myself how many shots of
olive oil it's quick 500 calories shot
olive oil down boom 500 calories got my
fats for the day there's only a few
foods I eat I don't eat vegetables
vegetables are bad for you I don't eat
nuts I don't need I basically just have
why are vegetables bad for you there's a
lot of uh things that aren't utilizable
for energy and a lot of I mean like
cucumbers is fine but for the most part
like I don't really like to eat like the
dark leafy greens it's not digestible
yeah spinach indigestible for humans a
lot of people don't realize this you
don't eat spinach no I don't really eat
vegetables ever just fruits fats and
meat so is that anything else that we're
told we must do
um that actually we shouldn't do and is
there anything else that um we're told
that we should do that we shouldn't do
everything in life ever ever since I was
a kid I remember all these teachers
telling me stuff and just being like
hell no not listening to you but for
example just something like sunscreen
every day I remember my mom used to come
and rub it all over my face like get out
of here I don't want to wear that
sunscreen then I started to realize wait
a second shit's bad for you don't wear
sunscreen I I can look at me I'm I'm you
know European I can go in the sun and be
completely fine for an hour I actually
build up a tolerance over time so I lay
in the Sun for like 30 minutes a day
usually I live in LA so it's it's
beautiful there it's always sunny and a
European guy like me would usually get
burnt but your skin is meant to absorb
sunlight I just sit there absorb the
energy and I won't get burnt over time
so don't be using the sunscreen
obviously don't be having seed oils all
this junk food just try it for like two
three weeks uh something for example
sleep optimizing your sleep I I fall
asleep very fast I have like special
tricks for that there's it's like a
military technique where you just relax
and fall asleep in like one two minutes
that just saves time
there's stuff like that and there's just
so many I could say a million different
things so how are you so I guess go back
to the sunscreen I'm obviously darker
than you and if I stay in the Sun for I
don't really burn but but I can burn and
if I stay in the Sun for too long so how
are you staying in the sun longer than
me humans are meant to build tolerance
to things if you do a bunch of drugs
you're gonna build a tolerance you know
if you if same with drinking it's just
like drinking maybe I drink once in my
life I'm obviously gonna get more drunk
than if you drink every day so it's the
same thing you just build up over time
if you sent the Sun for 30 minutes a day
and then the next week 40 minutes a day
the next week 50 minutes a day you're
not gonna get burned I know there's tons
like some of these Swedish guys I'm
friends with they they can get in the
sun with me because they're always in
the Sun so it's just natural another
thing is drugs like it's very mainstream
to be out there smoking weed and doing
all these drugs I'm very anti-drug
obviously alcohol and tobacco those are
the mainstream drugs I have no problem
with those enjoy your life I love
smoking cigars as much as everybody else
but all drugs in general I'm very
anti-weed I'm very anti especially hard
drugs there's just no point of it I have
a bunch of friends that smoke weed
that's that's their prerogative and it's
their choice but for me I've never
touched a drug and never will it's just
I made it this long I used to be an
athlete so I used to get drug tested so
I couldn't do them anyways but and
another thing is Adderall a lot of
people are always doing Adderall to
focus and whatnot you don't need that
stuff just don't drink water that's your
Adderall there you go
um yeah I mean coming from the the UK
I've even noticed how in the U.S
everybody's on drugs like I was working
on a summer camp when I was a kid yeah
actually when I was like 18 I was
working a summer camp and I saw all
these little kids running every morning
to take their ADHD medicine I'm like
what is going on this is an American
thing
it really is and you see in La it's an
actual just
Crazy Town degenerate as I say the
degeneracy of La is always crazy
everyone's on drugs there it's a normal
thing for a go to the club and do Molly
every night it's just absolutely crazy I
can't believe it it's uh it's probably
why I'm moving out soon you'll you'll
you'll go to the club you'll come out
there'll be a homeless guy defecating on
the street there's nothing good about it
it's basically if you want to go to La
there's a few things you can do you
basically just see a bunch of
promiscuous girls a bunch of homeless
people defecating you get taxed a lot
and you get herpes well you just go to
call just go to college for that it's
the same thing they're going to steal
your money in college They're Gonna Give
You herpes in college they're gonna be a
bunch of crazy girls around so it's
really hard to find first off good
people like like there's just all it is
is scammers and a bunch of terrible
people trying to take your value and
your money it's always such an LA thing
and they always ask you know what what
can what can you do oh you have a nice
watch on and then they'd come over like
if you're if I if you're wearing like a
track suit outfit like Just Like Old
Navy stuff they won't even show you the
time of the day but oh Rolex let me go
over you should invest in my app this
and that and the girls there it's just
there's nothing good about La that's
probably why I'm getting out there soon
the only reason I live there is because
uh my place in Beverly the only last
nice place to live is in Beverly Hills
and it's beautiful there like it but
probably leaving soon I think there's a
few places left on Earth that are worth
living in but for the most part I don't
recommend La so where on Earth is left
that's worth living depends what you
like so I have a bunch of friends that
live in Eastern Europe Eastern Europe's
great Spain I have friends who live in
Spain personally not for me I like uh
places that I guess organized crime is I
like to be able to go out on the street
and not feel like my 100 000 watch is
gonna get robbed for me so safety is
number one that's why Dubai is great I
love Tel Aviv Israel so that that's also
another option if you guys never visited
there check it out I think Miami is the
last place left in America there's
really nowhere what there's Miami Vegas
and La well I just talked about La Vegas
what you want to have a gambling
addiction yeah Miami it's quite nice in
some parts but for the most part there
needs to be
I think food is important tax is
important woman definitely important and
just not getting shot in the head for no
reason is important so yeah I'd say
Eastern Europe Dubai Miami most people
say the same yeah I think so everybody's
sort of saying um yeah Eastern Europe to
buy Miami yeah definitely
um so what's next for Gavin Mayo yeah so
obviously I have a lot of plans in store
you're not supposed to tell people your
goals they're less likely to come true
that's what they say but for the most
part I have big big plans Conquering the
world and whatnot but recently you know
we started the our brand backup earn
that's our Discord stuff we just teach
people how to trade you literally join
right now it's out on Instagram go in
there learn stuff for free education
section so that's number one I started
creating content again because I love it
you know it's nice to actually help
people and they have gotten to a stage
in my life where I'm wise enough I was
pretty young when I was 1920 when I was
talking about crypto but now I can
actually talk about other life stuff I
think I'm in the pioneering stage right
now where yeah I'm in my 20s but I'm
living the life of people that are in
their 30s because I've lived so much
life so fast so I think I have the right
to talk about a lot of this stuff so
obviously I want to start making videos
and lastly you know doing doing a bunch
of Charity type of stuff
going and trading making more money I
want to become a billionaire of course
everyone wants to become a billionaire
which mathematically it should happen
and that's when you really get to
influence the world so that's the plan
where can people find you and follow you
and get in contact with you yeah my
Instagram just at Mayo like mayonnaise m
a y o and YouTube earn Mayo at earn as
our company and yeah I'm also on Rumble
one on Twitter and Mayo you just go
check up all my all my stuff and you
won't find my actual account on Tick
Tock you'll probably just see a bunch of
videos of me talking because people just
posting about me so yeah amazing Gavin I
want to thank you so much for coming on
the show thank you so much interesting
um hearing your take on food sunlight
the market what's going on right now how
to find a [__] coin um I think it's been
super valuable so thank you so much
thank you so much I'm gonna make you
some uh raw chicken someday and yeah
thanks for having me absolutely I can't
wait for the raw chicken guys thank you
so much for watching please don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe and
we'll see you all next week